In this problem, a group of engineering
students was monitored while preparing
for the PE exam.
Researchers determined that the lowest
observed adverse effect level, or LOAEL,
for a substance known as caffeinium was
780 mg per day for an adult male
engineer.
At doses above this level, subjects
began exhibiting symptoms of sadness,
burnout, and repeatedly asking whether
they should have gone into finance
instead.
An uncertainty factor of 10 and a
modifying factor of 10 were applied to
develop a reference dose.
What is most nearly the resulting
reference dose in milligrams over
kilogram days?
So, this problem is quick and easy to
solve.
The problem statement already tells you
directly that it wants you to find the
reference dose.
For the environmental exam,
you can search reference dose,
and it will lead you directly to the
following equation.
RFD equals LOAEL over the uncertainty
factor times the modifying factor.
For the water resources exam, you can
also search reference dose, or RFD, but
it will lead you to a slightly different
equation, and I'm not sure why.
More about this in a minute.
So, this equation is pretty simple. So,
let's plug in our knowns. First, the
LOAEL. The units are not specified in
the environmental handbook, but they are
for NOAEL as mg over kg * day.
For some reason, in the water resources
manual, the reference dose units are
given instead.
And that is also the units which the
problem statement is asking for.
So, the problem statement states that
our LOAEL is 780 mg per day for an adult
male engineer.
Those last two words are important. They
tell us that we need to include the body
weight of an adult male in this problem
in order to satisfy the required units.
For the environmental homies, the
reference manual provides an adult male
body weight of 78 kg.
For the WRE folks, this would need to be
supplied as I don't think it's available
in the water resources manual.
So, our LOAEL will actually be 780 mg
per day divided by 78 kg.
And our uncertainty factor is given
directly as 10, and our modifying factor
is also given as 10.
One final callout for the water
resources exam.
The reference manual equation only shows
an uncertainty factor and does not
explicitly include a modifying factor.
If you encountered a problem like this
on the exam, I would expect the wording
to be clearer or for the modifying
factor to be incorporated into an
overall uncertainty factor.
So, simplifying to the correct units, we
can see that we get 10 mg over kg *
days.
Then, we can divide by 100 to get a
final answer of 0.1 mg over kg days.
This is identical to our first answer
option at the top.
So again, this problem is quick to solve
as long as you pay attention to the
units and don't forget to include body
weight.
If you do, there could be false answers
that you might accidentally solve for on
the exam.
And that's it.